viele bundesländer gibt es denn in
deutschland die 3 h
herzlich sondern gehört ich habe mein
bruder an meiner seite denn wir feiern
heute ein großes comeback und zwar leute
gibt es endlich wieder eine neue folge
asi tv sticks für euch zu diesem zweck
zu diesem großen comeback haben wir uns
ein video rausgesucht was youtube
wirklich verändert hat es gibt nur ganz
wenige videos wie sind titel verdient
haben aber dieses video hat ihn so was
von verdient wir reden von der umfrage
zum integrationstest von antworten von
teddy entscheidung auf dieses video zu
reagieren hat übrigens auch eine große
diskussion in der ethikkommission von
atv classics hervorgerufen blender ist
ist also tv das ist die große frage oder
eigentlich denkt sich vielleicht auch
froh dass ich hier alle tv aber leute
aber denkt zurück als dieses video raus
kamen dachten alle dass er es ernst
meint ja und dieses video ist so beliebt
geworden weil alle dachten dass es ernst
weil dann immer noch das denken 40
millionen aufrufe dieses video ist
gottes eine sache wir loslegen heute am
ende gibt's natürlich wieder die us tv
classics bewerteten die ihr schon kennt
das bleibt bis zum ende dran
zudem kann ich sie mal kurz fragen
da ging's los liga aber man muss
wirklich sagen teddy ist einfach einer
der gold comedians in deutschland new
york also ich wirklich für diesen mann
einfach nur liebe wohnt in unserer stadt
ich glaube der bund auch in köln das ist
auch in köln gefilmt das video das ist
fan der straße oder glaube ich habe ein
paar fragen zum integrationstest man den
integrationstest möglich er war halt
auch seiner zeit voraus da ist so 2011
da gab es noch kein kollektives
verständnis von satire und so etwas im
internet sondern es gibt ja auch andere
geschichten von dem game markiert die
hören gerne wünschen dass die leute
haben es noch nicht gecheckt ein paar
ganz allgemeine fragen ganz einfach
erster wer zum beispiel wer ist
deutschlands bundeskanzler
dass sich der erwartete wahl seine
stimme und seine sprache als anton hat
sich auch voll weiterentwicklung auf
jeden fall der die rolle nachricht
gesteigert und man muss auch mal fett
ist aber den kameramann geben ja also
dass deshalb gleich immer dabei das ist
der gleiche tod von damals de gaia
[Musik]
später angelo näherte ist immer noch an
der macht gibt es nur eine sache zu
sagen warum gehen sie auf die straße
man muss einen anton hat wenig hätte
dazu bekommen hat einige räte dazu
bekommt wer waren
angela merkel wäre richtig gewesen dies
bestätigt der typ am telefon an nokia 82
10 andy was nicht kaputt gehen kann hat
gesagt dass angelo
damit ist bestätigt welche quellen kann
man anführen um tatsachen zu bestätigen
wissenschaftler
nein oder typ der handy wo vielleicht
ich mal dran ist wahrscheinlich nicht zu
hören warum also so angelo hatte wurde
das ganze land leute und eine miene zu
verziehen
die leute am ende des videos gibt's auch
eine sprüche bewertung wie immer bei atv
classics wird auch der sprüche faktor
bewertet also bleibt bis zum ende dran
und da wird einiges pfeffern hier auf
jeden fall hitler kann das sein
noch fragen er weiß alles
[Gelächter]
egal was für ein großer schock ich
wünschte mir ich wäre in diesem video
dabei gewesen das ist zu krank
das ist von neun jahren ist es
hochgeladen worden stellt euch vor der
waren einfach zwei typ auf der straße
hat eine dumme idee und guckt euch an
wie das explodiert ist
er sagt mir dass ein bauer in
deutschland gewaltig was für mich zu
fahren schnell auf mich zu verstellen
[Gelächter]
wie kann man die rolle von anton
beschreiben so so harzer als der eagles
aggressives schwabl aber auch so spare
übrigens zurückhaltend aber bis jetzt
ist also haben wir doch überschätzt der
haut die immer von ihm ab aber er denkt
auch wenn der kassen für die
bundesländer gibt es denn in deutschland
ist
westfalen niedersachsen hessen
baden-württemberg 1 das war es dass ein
land also eher tür in sachsen sachsen
anhalt mecklenburg vorpommern und dem
winter hamburg hamburg dann sollten wir
drei kinder ohne telefonjoker ohne mit
der wimper 20 also was laberst du aber
ohne telefon
[Musik]
aber auch gut 20 auch kann man auch
zählen lassen kann natürlich irgendwann
irgendwer mit alter zwischen mitte von
20 und 3 also 23 2 also in deutschland
elf bundesländer stimmt ja keine ahnung
drei dieser dieser verächtliche
gesichtsausdruck so etwas will was will
dieser reporter auch ganz ehrlich ja
integriert was für integrationstest ist
ein schnauzer in new york die deutschen
die stabil
er wusste damals noch nicht die
hauptstadt von deutschland auch immer so
früher in der schule immer gut spruch ja
also ganz ehrlich sprüche faktor ist
wirklich zu mit top kommentar unter
diesem video leute falls es uns nicht
glaubt haarig schreibt sind wir mal
ehrlich wir dachten doch früher alle es
sei echt das ist mit abstand die beste
schauspielerische leistung im
deutschsprachigen raum gesehen na ja er
hat uns damals alle hochgenommen
da die fast der frage mitreden nämlich
keine hauptstadt kind war war fangfrage
tatsächlich welches stets ausgelassen ja
verrückt so was für einen sieg ist denn
dieser interview ja deutschland hat
einfach keine hauptstadt ganz nett wie
viele einwohner hat deutschland ganz
deutschland aber mit eu aber mit ohne eu
also nur deutschland deutscher teil 20
30.000 30 30
diese mimik dabei er ist aber so
straight facebook lässt sich nichts
anmerken hilfe aber hat er bis heute
nacht lag ich weiß wie das ist wo wir
vorne ist der rewe echt und 200 meter
davon war meine erste wohnung in köln
ich sehe mich nicht wiederholen heute
aber ist es wirklich krank sehr heftiges
ergebnis zu sehen also die der dichter
überhaupt hier was tun sie für die
integration
wie schreibt man das machen was machen
sie denn zum beispiel darum sich zu
integrieren
diesen worten wollen wir jetzt in die
bewertung übergeben kommen wir zum spaß
faktor auf einer skala von 1 bis 10 am
anfang war man eher wissen schockiert es
ist auch nicht so ein reiner ich würde
neun geben wird ich dann noch davor
sprüche von 10 11 10 11 10 11
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßen
faktor 0 0 in zwei etappen halt am
anfang dachte man sich mal als buch vor
der saison meine frau und sohn aber
eigentlich nur 0 legende status auch
wieder eine 11 liegen statt das ist eine
elfte gast
es ist so wild im hintergrund ist hier
mit dem haus haben wollte damit
verabschieden wir euch auch heute die
kriterien vorgestellten können abonniert
finden der schüler raus und wie schlange
ist insofern brisant